You're still here?
It's perseverance.
I started talking about how within physical security we care about the infrastructure support systems.
And by that I mean making sure that we provide a good clean supply of power, network, and HVAC.
So let's talk through each of these pieces, actually two of them in detail, power and HVAC.
And we're going to start with power.
And the goal within physical security is to have a good clean consistent supply of power.
And there's a few components that we need to talk about that provide that good clean consistent supply of electricity of power.
Let's start with UPS's uninterruptible power supplies.
UPS's are essentially giant batteries.
And they provide two primary capabilities for us.
One is that as soon as the power goes out they provide instantaneous but short term power.
And by that I mean the electricity is running through this giant battery on its way into the building.
And so if the power from the mains cuts then the UPS giant battery provides instantaneous power to the rest of the building.
But only for a short period of time.
The other thing the UPS provides is what we refer to as power conditioning.
There's rectification and other circuitry in within these systems typically that will clean up the power.
And what I mean by that is that alternate and current AC current, if you look at it on a oscilloscope it should be a nice perfect sine wave.
But if the amplitude is too high, the frequency is too high or too low, you get dirty power, spikes, things like that.
And dirty power, bad for equipment.
So UPS's can clean up the power.
Now I mentioned that UPS's only provide power for a short period of time until what happens.
Until the generator gets up to speed.
Because the next major device we have to talk about are generators.
Typically very large diesel engines hooked up to an alternator.
Now if we have this big generator that's able to produce power for the entire facility, why do we still need the UPS?
Generators being big diesel engines, typically they take time to spin up to get up to speed.
Sometimes 20, 30, 40, 50, even 60 seconds before they're online up and running and providing power.
And so our UPS has covered this short window from when the power from the mains is cut and when the generator is up to speed.
So that's the use of the UPS. Now generators.
Because they're big diesel engines, they require maintenance.
I've seen a couple of organizations that have had this problem.
They've bought a generator, they've put it out in the parking lot, they've never touched it, never run it for 10 years.
The power went out and what did the generator do?
Nothing.
These things require maintenance.
Usually a good idea to power these things on at least once a month, do yearly load tests.
Don't have to remember any of these exact sort of numbers for the exam, but do recognize that generators need constant maintenance, well-defined maintenance schedules.
You also have to think about what percentage of the building can the generator supply the whole building by itself?
Do you need multiple of them together? What amount of power can they supply?
And how much fuel do you have?
You have to think about how long of power outage are we expecting?
How long do we need to stay up and running for?
And you need to have at least that amount of fuel supply in a tank somewhere nearby.
And related to this, you have to usually have contracts in place.
So if you know that you only have 72 hours worth of fuel on site,
you should probably have a contract in place that's going to get you fuel in less than 72 hours, 48 hours, something like that.
A lot of organizations recently learned a hard lesson related to this in Texas.
When the most recent cyclone came through Texas and knocked out all sorts of buildings and infrastructure,
lots of companies had backup generators and those backup generators were running and those companies had contracts with fuel suppliers in Texas.
But the hard lesson they learned is that when FEMA came in, when the federal government came in to help clean up the mess,
they made sure really important services like fire and police stations and hospitals had power.
They just took the fuel basically.
They basically said the fuel, I forget the proper term right now, but they said the fuels are as we needed for critical services.
And it doesn't matter what contracts you might have in place, we're using it for these critical services.
And so these organizations, even though they had fuel contracts in place, still ran out of fuel and their systems went down.
So a lot of these, a lot of companies now are looking at putting in place fuel supply contracts that are out of state.
Now, we now have to talk about a few different types of power outages.
These first two here, blackouts, faults. This is a complete and total loss of power.
A blackout is a complete and total loss of power for a long period of time.
And a fault is a complete and total loss of power for a very short period of time.
The next three, brownout, sags, dips and surges, these are about not complete power loss but power and degradation.
So a brownout is a long period of time of too low of voltage.
This is usually intentionally done by utilities companies in order to insert it instead of having a complete blackout,
they'll have a brownout where it's not total as much power as you want, but at least it's nothing.
Sags and dips are short, brief moments of not enough power and surges are brief moments of way too much power.
Think lightning strikes.
The other thing we have to be concerned with with power is electrical noise, EMI, RFI.
These are examples of where we get noise on the electrical line.
And this is why we have things like shielding around our and twisted pair in our networking devices, stuff like that.
Let's now talk about HVAC equipment, heating, ventilation and air conditioning.
Our HVAC systems are what provide air at the perfect temperature, the perfect humidity and filtered into the building and into our data centers.
Now, happy to report you don't have to remember the actual temperature ranges, humidity ranges and so forth for the exam,
but you do need to know roughly what these HVAC systems are for.
So number one, they provide air at the right temperature, because especially we as people we like air to be the right temperature, or else we're miserable,
but we also use air within a data center, for instance, to do what?
Well, that air is being brought, that cool air is being brought into the data center to cool the equipment.
It's all being sucked through the front of the server, run through the heat sinks at a server and exhaust it out the back.
So that air has to be the right temperature in order to properly cool the servers and keep them from overheating.
We also have to provide air at the right humidity.
What happens if the air is too dry, if there's not enough humidity?
You get static, you get shorts.
What happens if the air is too humid?
You get condensation, water and electricity, bad, so too low, static, too high humidity.
And then the final thing is air quality.
You want to remove contaminants, dust, debris, things like that from the air, filter the air before it's brought into the data center.
For that reason, I already talked about why do we bring air into a data center to cool the servers?
And if that air has dust, dirt, debris in it, you're going to be sucking that air through the servers,
clogging the heat sinks, clogging the system up with dirt and debris, they're going to overheat, short out, bad.
And there's one final bit of terminology you should be aware of related to HVAC systems.
And that is positive pressurization.
And this is the idea that we want to pump the air into the building, into the, especially the data center, at slightly above ambient pressure.
Not much, but a little bit.
And you probably experience this.
If you walk into a mall or something like that and you open the door and you get this rush of air coming at you, that's positive pressurization.
The reason we want that in a data center is that if the air is positively pressurized, if anyone opens a door, if there's any cracks in the building,
anything like that, you're forcing out nice, clean, filtered air and you're not letting dirty air contaminants come into the building.
So that's positive pressurization.